Let's just finish out this tutorial by creating a quite a quick 3D UMG widget which creates
some kind of stylized display in the world.
So we'll create a new 3D widget which I'll jump into my editor here and show you and
essentially we can just render the speed of the UMG in the actual world so we can see
the speed changing to reflect the UI.
So in the editor here just right click, user interface and the widget blueprint selected.
I've called this 3D display menu.
So if I open this up you'll see that we have the canvas panel in place, we have just a
background color which you can see here width and height is 200 and then we've also got
some kind of bar here which I've bound to a progress bar which I will dig into in a
second here and we've also got the speed text which is the vehicle display which again
will bound to a set text functionality which again we'll go over in a second here.
Now the actual styling doesn't matter so much something along the lines of some text
and a bar is good here, a progress bar and if we go into our vehicle blueprint now you
can see that we've got this 3D widget component.
So we can actually go to add and we can go to widget and you can actually add a widget
into your blueprint and the widget class is going to be that 3D display widget.
So you can see here if I just delete this empty one now you'll see that this 3D widget
just has a location and a rotation kind of moved it out.
We've got the widget class set here so now when you actually go into the map you can
see this widget displayed in real time which is really nice if you want some kind of visualization
that's actually presented in the scene rather than just 2D on the user interface.
So go ahead and compile and save and let's look at the blueprinting involved in this
display menu.
So first of all we want to use pre-construct again so we've got our pre-construct if you
just right click enter pre-construct and then we want to right click get player controller,
drag off the blue player controller and display controller and then the display controller
we want to get the hood reference and then we want to get the input UMG promote that
to a variable set that as the input UMG reference so input UMG you just want to set that there.
And then on the actual function side so when we've added functions we've got the speed
bar which if we go back into the designer the speed bar we want to create a binding
called speed bar and if I go back into here let's see what's going on.
So we've got the input reference so we drag off here holding down control drag off we've
got the car speed UI which is what we've created previously and you can just return that node
there and then the set text in a similar way we can go to the set text we've got a bound
event here so set text is our binding and essentially what we're doing in this function
is we're getting the UMG again so drag out here we're getting our car speed UI we've got our map
range clamped at 0 to 1 and then 0 to 150 on the out range and then we want to floor that value
and in a similar way as we formatted the speed before if you drag out here type format text you
want to type in speed and then add value in this the swirly brackets and then that will give you
a value input which you can plug in that floor value there so that's essentially what we've got
going on quick overview of a little UMG widget but hopefully that gives you an idea about is a similar
functionality if we've done previously but instead of it being on the 2d interface we've now got this
3d widget which if we jump into the map now just check out what's going on if I just full screen
this and press Alt and P you'll see that we've got our value in here we've got the car speed
going up and down so you can see that that value changing and then the things that we've done
before you'll see the airspeed changing and then also the temperature change in there so we've got
some nice basic UMG functionality going on here again the styling could change but the main thing
is that we've learned how to communicate between UMG and blueprints so let's go ahead and close
out this tutorial in the next video